हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबसे पहले आप मुझे यह
बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है प्लीज चैट
में यस या नो बता दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू टेक्नो
स्पार्क एंड मक्खन राम जी नमस्कार एंड हाय
नोक्स
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं। जी हेलो
थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं 30 सेकंड का। उसके
बाद हम अपने टॉपिक को स्टार्ट कर देंगे।
तो कोई मुझे यह बताएगा जो स्टूडेंट अभी
प्रेजेंट हैं। हमने लास्ट क्लास में क्या
पढ़ा था? और जो मैं आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं,
क्या आप लोग उसको प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हो या
नहीं कर रहे हो? यह बताओ। आप उसको
प्रैक्टिस करते हो?
शायद मुझे लगता है कि प्रैक्टिस नहीं करते
आप लोग।
करते हो? ओके। तो लास्ट क्लास में मैंने
आपको क्या पढ़ाया था? किसी को याद है?
किसी को भी याद है लास्ट क्लास में हमने
क्या पढ़ा था?
तो लास्ट क्लास में अगर आप लोगों को याद
होगा मैंने आपको एक प्रैक्टिकल सेशन
करवाया था जिसमें हमने क्या किया? हमने
अपने टारगेट मशीन के अंदर टेम डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर एक्सc
का पेलोड डाउनलोड किया था। डाउनलोड करने
के बाद उसको एग्जीक्यूट करवाया था और वहां
से हमने रिवर्स सेल लिया था। यह चीज हमने
पढ़ाई थी लास्ट क्लास में। अगर आप लोगों
को याद हो तो
अगर आप लोगों को याद हो तो लास्ट क्लास
में मैंने यह चीज आप लोगों को पढ़ाई थी।
क्या सबको याद है यह चीज?
तो आज का सेशन भी वहीं से आगे से स्टार्ट
होता है। इन द प्रीवियस सेशन वी ऑब्जर्व
डाउनलोडिंग एन एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल
डायरेक्टली इनू द टेम फोल्डर और
डायरेक्टरी ऑन ए टारगेट मशीन ट्रिगर्स एन
इमीडिएट रिस्प मींस सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स
डिटेक्ट एंड डिलीट द बाइनरी इंस्ट
इंस्टेंटली। जैसे कि आपने देखा भी था।
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने किया था। जैसे ही
हमने जो अपना मिशियस पेलोड था उसको टारगेट
मशीन के ऊपर क्या किया था?
भेजा था। और जैसे ही यूजर ने डबल क्लिक
किया डबल क्लिक के बाद इनेबल कंटेंट किया
था। इनेबल कंटेंट करने के बाद जो एक फाइल
थी exई exc फाइल थी हमारी डॉट exc फाइल थी
जिसको हमने एक टेम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
स्टोर किया था और उसको एग्जीक्यूट करने की
कोशिश की तो सेम टाइम क्या हो रहा था जो
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स था सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स उसको डिटेक्ट कर रहा था और
डिटेक्ट करके उसको डिलीट कर दिया था
नॉर्मल बात है क्योंकि हम कोई हाईफाई पे
लोड नहीं डिजाइन कर रहे थे मैं जस्ट आपको
कांसेप्ट बता रहा हूं कि ऐसे चीजें भेजी
जाती है उसके लिए फिर आपको एडवांस बढ़ने
के लिए बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं। इन
इंजेक्शन टेक्निक्स होती है। मेमोरी
टेक्निक्स होती है। ऑफस होता है हाई लेवल
पर। उसके बहुत बाद आपको बहुत सारी चीजें
उससे पहले पता होनी चाहिए। वो दे आर लॉट
ऑफ टेक्निक्स। तो वह बहुत एडवांस टेक्निक
होती है। यह बिल्कुल बेसिक है क्योंकि अगर
आपको मैं जो भी कुछ यहां पर बताने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं उसको आप डायरेक्टली
एग्जीक्यूट करने की कोशिश करोगे टारगेट
मशीन के ऊपर जिसके ऊपर इवन Windows
डिफेंडर या रियल टाइम प्रोडक्शंस भी ऑन
होगा तब भी आपकी फाइल डिलीट हो जाएगी और
डिटेक्ट हो जाएगी। ये चीज हमने प्रीवियस
क्लास में क्या की थी? डिस्कस की तो हमने
ये चीज ऑब्जर्व की थी कि जैसे मैंने फाइल
को इंस्टॉल किया था या जैसे ही फाइल मैंने
टेम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर भेजी थी डाउनलोड
की थी तो सेम टाइम वो फाइल क्या हो रही थी
डिलीट हो रही थी तो अब इस केस में एक रेड
टीमर क्या करेगा अब जब इस केस में एक रेड
टीमर क्या करेगा
रेड टीमर अपनी स्ट्रेटजी को चेंज करेगा
अपनी स्ट्रेटजी को चेंज करेगा और अब वो
कौन सी स्ट्रेटजी का यूज करेगा करेगा वो
यूज़ करेगा फाइललेस एग्जीक्यूशन।
फाइललेस एग्जीक्यूशन मतलब मैं अभी टम
डायरेक्टरी के ऊपर डाउनलोड नहीं करने
वाला। बल्कि मैं क्या करने वाला हूं?
बल्कि मैं
एक स्क्रिप्ट को जो पावर सेल स्क्रिप्ट है
उसको क्या करने वाला हूं? उसको डाउनलोड
करने के बजाय RAM के अंदर ही क्या करूंगा?
लेकर आऊंगा। और लाइव रैम के अंदर ही उसको
क्या करूंगा? डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट कर
दूंगा बिना डाउनलोड किए। मतलब मैं हार्ड
डिस्क पर उसको नहीं ले जाने वाला। मैं
उसको हार्ड डिस्क पर नहीं डाउनलोड करने
वाला। जब हार्ड डिस्क पर फाइल डाउनलोड
नहीं होने वाली तो उस केस में क्या होगा?
उस केस में आपकी जो फिजिकल मशीनंस है उसका
कोई सवाल ही नहीं उठता कि उसको क्वारंटाइन
या डिलीट कर दे। क्योंकि कोई फाइल आपकी
हार्ड डिस्क पर सेव नहीं हो रही। ठीक है?
बाय रनिंग एंटायरली विद इन रैम या मेमोरी
और लीविंग नो एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल्स ऑन द
हार्ड डिस्क ट्रेडिशनल एंटीवायर सॉलशंस आर
लेफ्ट विद नथिंग फिजिकल टू क्वारंटाइन और
डिलीट। वही जैसे कि अगर मैं रैेम के अंदर
डायरेक्टली उस फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा
हूं, रन कर रहा हूं तो हार्ड डिस्क पर कोई
भी फाइल सेव नहीं हो रही। जब हार्ड डिस्क
पे कोई फाइल सेव नहीं हो रही तो मतलब जो
एंटीवायर सॉलशंस है जो सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस
है उसको क्वारंटाइन और डिलीट नहीं कर
सकते। उसको क्वारेंटाइन और डिलीट नहीं कर
सकते। तो नेक्स्ट तो अभी हमारा जो
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन है उसमें हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? उसमें हम तीन स्टेप
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं। चौथे स्टेप में तो
हम एग्जीक्यूट ही कर देंगे। फर्स्ट स्टेप
हमारा क्या रहेगा हमारा? हम डाउनलोड
करेंगे पावर कैट स्क्रिप्ट को। उसके बाद
डाउनलोड करने के बाद हम फाइल को कहां से
डाउनलोड करेंगे? इंटरनेट से। अपनी अटैकर
मशीन के अंदर अपनी काली लin के अंदर हम
guब से जो पावर कैट की स्क्रिप्ट है उसको
डाउनलोड करेंगे। डाउनलोड करने के बाद उसको
क्या करेंगे? होस्ट करेंगे। डाउनलोड करने
के बाद उसको हम क्या करने वाले हैं? होस्ट
करने वाले हैं। किसके ऊपर? अपने टारगेट
सर्वर अपने अटैकर मशीन के ऊपर मतलब हम एक
सर्वर का रोल भी प्ले करेंगे। जब एक बार
हम क्या कर लेंगे उस स्क्रिप्ट को डाउनलोड
करने के बाद होस्ट कर लेंगे अपने लोकल
एचटीटीपी सर्वर के ऊपर उसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे? एक लिसनर सेटअप करेंगे। एक नेटकट
लिसनर सेटअप करेंगे या एक रिसीवर सेटअप
करेंगे। जो क्या करेगा? आने वाले कनेक्शन
को क्या करेगा? लिसन करेगा। रिसीव करेगा।
कहां से? क्योंकि जब जो पावर सेल
स्क्रिप्ट आप डाउनलोड करोगे गिट हब से
उसको जब आपका जो टारगेट यूजर है जो आपका
टारगेट सिस्टम है जब उसको एग्जीक्यूट
करेगा एग्जीक्यूट करने के बाद वो क्या
करने की कोशिश करेगी एक रिवर्स सेल
कनेक्शन बनाने की कोशिश करेगी रिवर्स
कनेक्शन जब वो रिवर्स कनेक्शन आएगा अटैकर
मशीन के पास तो उसके लिए हम क्या करते हैं
एक रिसीवर सेटअप करते हैं एक लिसनर सेटअप
करेंगे ताकि वह कनेक्शन को रिसीव करके
क्या कर दे उसके साथ एक कनेक्शन
एस्टैब्लिश कर दे टारगेट मशीन के साथ और
हमें सेल एक्सेस प्रोवाइड कर दे फर्दर
क्यूरी के लिए फर्दर काम करने के लिए। तो
स्टेप टू हमारा क्या रहेगा? नेट कैट लिसनर
सेटअप करना। ठीक है? ऑन द डेकर मशीन स्पिन
अप ए नेटक कैट लिसनर टू कैप्चर द इनकमिंग
कनेक्शन फ्रॉम द टारगेट। यह थे दो स्टेप।
पहला स्टेप यह था। दूसरा स्टेप आपका यह
था। तीसरे स्टेप में हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? तीसरे स्टेप में हम करने वाले हैं
अपनी वीबीए स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर या वीबीए के
अंदर एक मिलिशियस मैक पेलोड डेवलप करेंगे
जिसके अंदर हम क्या करेंगे हम
उस पेलोड के द्वारा उसको हम क्या करेंगे
आपके टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर भेजेंगे टारगेट
मशीन उस पे डबल क्लिक करेगा डबल क्लिक
करने इनेबल कंटेंट करेगा इनेबल कंटेंट
करने के बाद जो स्क्रिप्ट हमने होस्ट की
है उस स्क्रिप्ट को क्या करेगा मेमोरी के
अंदर एग्जीक्यूट करवा करवाएगा। एग्जीक्यूट
करवाने के बाद उसको रिवर्स कनेक्शन क्रिएट
करेगा। तो ये है हमारा एक्चुअल हमारा
प्रोसेस प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन जो हम
करने वाले हैं। तो चलिए फिर हम पहले एक
काम करते हैं। अपने कोड को डिजाइन करते
हैं। स्टेप बाय स्टेप प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के लिए। कोड डिजाइन करने के
बाद हम क्या करेंगे? मैं आपको यह समझाऊंगा
कि बिहाइंड द सीन यह चीज कैसे काम करेगी
कि जब आपके टारगेट यूजर ने उस पर डबल
क्लिक किया डबल क्लिक करने के बाद बिहाइंड
द सीन क्या हुआ मतलब आपकी स्क्रिप्ट में
ऐसा कौन सा फंक्शन था जो उसको क्या करने
वाला वो बिहाइंड द सीन जो हमें क्या बोला
जो कि आपकी स्क्रिप्ट को मेमोरी के अंदर
एग्जीक्यूट करवाएगा वो फंक्शन कैसे काम
किया उसके बारे में हम क्या करेंगे काफी
काफी डिटेल्स में देखने वाले हैं। तो चलिए
फिर हम प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पे चलते हैं।
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन पे चलने के लिए हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा? हमारे
स्क्रिप्ट के ऊपर चलना पड़ेगा और
स्क्रिप्ट के ऊपर भी ये रहा आ गया। तो
इससे भी पहले मैं क्या करने वाला हूं?
इससे भी पहले मैं काली लेस के ऊपर चलता
हूं। हमें कुछ चीजें करनी थी। तो मैं आपको
पावर भी बता दूंगा कि पावर होता क्या है।
ओके तो ब्राउज़र पे हम जाते हैं और ब्राउज़र
पे ओपन क्या करते हैं? हम पावर CAT सर्च
करते हैं। ब्राउज़र पे हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? Power CAT कुछ यहां पर हमें क्या है?
Power CAT सर्च करेंगे। तो इसका एक गेट
लिंक आएगा। यह रहा यह फर्स्ट वन। ठीक है?
अगर आपको नहीं पता हो, मैं इसको एक काम कर
देता हूं।
यह रहा। ओके। यहां पर आपको दिखाई दे रहा
होगा गेट हब है। यह रहा powercड वाला ये
नाउ ये आपका पावर का लिंक।
तो ये क्या है? पावर कैट एक प्रकार का
क्या है? पावर सेल वर्जन है। Netcat लिसनर
का। Netcat लिसनर का एक पावर कैट वर्जन।
यह net लिसनर का एक वर्जन है। पावर सेल
वर्जन है। पावर इज़ अ पावरफुल फंक्शन।
फर्स्ट ऑफ़ ऑल यू नीड टू लोड द फंक्शन
बिफोर यू कैन एग्जीक्यूट इट। यू कैन पुट
वन ऑफ़ द बिलो कमांड इंटू योर पावरसेल
प्रोफाइल। सो पावर कैट इज़ ऑटोमेटिकली
लोडेड व्हेन पावर सेल स्टार्ट्स। दीज़ आर द
पैरामीटर्स। दिस इज़ अ दिस इज़ द बेसिक
कनेक्शंस। बाय डिफॉल्ट पावर कैट रीड्स
इनपुट फ्रॉम द कंसोल एंड राइट्स इनपुट टू
द कंसोल यूजिंग राइट होस्ट उसके बाद आप
फाइल ट्रांसफर भी कर सकते हो पावर कैट कैन
बी यूज्ड टू सेंड एंड सर्व सेल स्पेसिफाई
एंड एग्जीक्यूटेबल टू हफन इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो सेल एक्सेस विद दे जो हम
रिवर्स कनेक्शन के लिए यूज़ करने वाले हैं
तो ये है इसके आप पावर कट के बारे में
जानकारी खुद से पढ़ सकते हो तो अभी हम
क्या करने वाले हैं यहां से इसको कॉपी
करते हैं। कॉपी करने के बाद हम अपने कहां
पर चलते हैं? टर्मिनल के ऊपर। हम चलते हैं
अपने टर्मिनल के ऊपर। तो टर्मिनल पर चलकर
हम क्या करने वाले हैं? गिट क्लोन करने
वाले हैं। तो चलिए फिर हम गेट क्लोन
ऑलरेडी मैं पहले कर चुका हूं। इट्स ओके।
गेट क्लोन एचटीटीपीएस इस तरीके से और ये
आपका वो लिंक है। हिट एंटर किया एंड
ऑलरेडी एकिस्ट इज़ नॉट। ओके। ऑलरेडी
एग्जिस्ट दिखा रहा है। ओके
सी नाउ सॉरी एक मिनट गेट क्लोन
और अभी हम एक काम करके देखते हैं।
पेस्ट क्लिपबोर्ड ये रहा पावर गेट हिट
ऑलरेडी ये अवेलेबल है। अगर मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं एलएस करके दिखाऊं तो यहां पर
ऑलरेडी है। यह रहा पावर गेट वाला। तो इस
तरीके से जब इसको आप गिट क्लोन करोगे गिट
क्लोन करने के बाद एक पावर नाम का फोल्डर
क्रिएट हो जाएगा। तो आपको क्या करना है?
सीडी पावर
cd power हिट एंटर उसके बाद एलएस लिस्ट
करोगे तो यहां पर आपको मिलेगी एक
स्क्रिप्ट पावर डॉट पीs1 तो इसके लिए हम
क्या करेंगे? यहां पर एक python सर्वर का
यूज़ करेंगे http वो करने के लिए सर्वर
इस्टैब्लिश करने के लिए। तो अभी मुझे
इस्टैब्लिश करने की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि
मुझे सिर्फ पावर कैट को क्या करना है?
पहले इसके लिए हम अपनी एक वीबीए पेलोड
डेवलप कराएंगे। एक मिलिशियस
वीबीए बेस्ड मैलोड डेवलप करेंगे। उसके बाद
ही हम इसको फदर एक्शंस लेंगे। तो चलिए हम
इसके बाद चलते हैं। ओके वेट वेट।
यह इसका ही है।
नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं स्क्रिप्ट के ऊपर। तो
चलो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं पहले। अब बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। तो
जैसे कि आप सबको पता है हम क्या करते हैं?
ऑप्शन एक्सप्लसिट।
अब केवल हार्ड एंड फास्ट नहीं बनाने वाला
मैं। ठीक है? अब क्या बिल्कुल छोटा सा
पेलोड बनाएंगे ताकि आपको भी समझ में आ
जाए।
यह क्या है?
फाइलस
पावर गेट मैक
पे लोड।
उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं? ठीक है?
ग्लोबल वेरिएबल डिफाइन करने वाले हैं।
सबसे पहले हम
प्राइवेट इज
क्योंकि ये तो इतना कॉमन हो गया आपके लिए
वेरिएबल्स डिफाइन करना। मुझे बार-बार आपको
एक्सप्लेन करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
इज़ ऑलरेडी पोलियन। एक ग्लोबल वेरिएबल है।
उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन फंक्शन
ओपन एंड यहां उसके बाद सेम वही हर बार की
तरह
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद
एक फंक्शन को कॉल बाद में करेंगे हम।
फोटो ओपन
नेक्स्ट अभी हम अपना फंक्शन क्रिएट
करेंगे।
फंक्शन और अभी हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
एग्जीक्यूट
पावर कैच बस
ये रहा ये हम फंक्शन क्रिएट कर रहे हैं
अभी और इस फंक्शन को हम क्या करेंगे कॉल
कर देंगे हर जगह
यह रहा देन यहां पर भी
देन उसके बाद हम चलते हैं। अभी सबसे पहले
एक कंडीशन लगा लेते हैं। इफ इज ऑलरेडी
यहां पर एक चेक लगा रहे हैं कि अगर यह
फंक्शन एक बार एग्जीक्यूट हो गया तो
बार-बार एग्जीक्यूट करने की जरूरत नहीं
है। क्योंकि पता चला है कि आप बार-बार
एग्जीक्यूट करोगे तो इससे भी वह हो जाएगा।
सस्पिशियस एक्टिविटी डिटेक्ट होती है।
बार-बार आप मेमोरी के अंदर एक चीज को
एग्जीक्यूट करके देख रहे हो।
एग्जीक्यूट
एग्जीक्यूटेड मे बी इट्स फाइन
करूंगा मैं इसको पहले
अब की बार मैं गलती नहीं करना चाहता
मिनिमम मिस्टेक चेक करना चाहता हूं मैं
ट्रू देन
एग्जिट
एग्जिट और सब
उसके बाद ये हो गया हमारा इफ कंडीशन उसके
बाद फिर से इज ऑलरेडी इक्वल टू
अब क्या यहां पर लिखा क्योंकि एक बार
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा
डम यूआरएल
एज स्ट्रिंग
डम टीएस
शिफ्ट
एच स्ट्रिंग
उसके बाद एक और वेरिएबल चाहिए हमें सेल
कमांड के लिए
टीएमडी
हो गया।
उसके बाद
यूआरएल अब यहां पर हम यूआरएल मेंशन करेंगे
अपना
http
उसके बाद
192.168.19.134
उसके बाद पोर्ट में यूज़ करूंगा 8080
उसके बाद मैं क्या करने वाला हूं? देन
हमारी पावर सेल उसका स्क्रिप्ट का नाम। तो
हमारी पावर स्क्रिप्ट का नाम क्या है? यह
देखते हैं।
यह रही
ओपी सिलेक्शन।
चलो
हो गया। यहां पर हो गया कंप्लीट आपका।
उसके बाद यह था हमारा
कमेंट मेंशन कर देता हूं आपके लिए।
अटैकर
मशीन
पोस्टेड
पावर कैच
स्क्रिप्ट एड्रेस।
ओके ये हो गया। नेक्स्ट अभी एक काम करता
हूं। मैं एक और कमेंट पास कर देता हूं।
डाउनलोड्स
क्रिप्ट इनू मेमोरी या रैेम
यूजिंग
आई एक्स
अब ये क्या चीज होता है? यही वो मेन पेलोड
है जो आपकी पूरी स्क्रिप्ट का पूरी आपकी
स्क्रिप्ट का आपके पे सबसे मेन पेलोड ही
यही है आपके लिए तो चलो इसको अभी करते हैं
फिर पीएस
स्क्रिप्ट के बाद हम करते हैं इक्वल
आई एक्स ब्रैकेट
न्यू ऑब्जेक्ट
सिस्टम डॉट नेट डॉट वेब क्लाइंट
मैं इसको समझाऊंगा
डॉट डाउनलोड
स्ट्रिंग
एंड
यूआरएल एंड
ब्रैकेट कंप्लीट ये एक कमांड है। उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट कमांड आपकी
पावर कैट
हफ
192.168.119.134
अपनी मशीन का आईपी एड्रेस अटैकर मशीन का
आईपी एड्रेस जिसके पास हमें रिवर्स
कनेक्शन भेजना है। उसके बाद hfन पोर्ट कौन
सा मैं यूज़ करने वाला हूं? 1337 पे यूज़
करने वाला हूं। देन हफन ए और सीएमडी चाहिए
मुझे। तो यह मेरी कमांड हो गई कंप्लीट। आई
होप ये हो गया आपकी अनएक्सेक्टेड
एक्सप्रेशन।
ओके आर एल
ओके ये रहा।
यह इस तरीके से गुड। नेक्स्ट अभी हम क्या
करना है? साइलेंटली हम इसको यूज़ अभी
एग्जीक्यूट भी करने वाले हैं। तो
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे?
सेल सीएमडी इक्वल यही है हमारा नेक्स्ट
वेरिएबल।
एंड सबको समझ में आ रहा है? प्लीज मुझे ये
बताओ।
किसी के लिए कुछ ऐसा तो नहीं कि नया है
सर।
पावर सेलx
मुझे तो लगता नहीं किसी के लिए नया होगा।
बाईपास हफन
विंडो
स्टाइल
हिडन
सी
पीएसप्ट
एमसेंट
उसके बाद
किसी के लिए नया है ऐसा लग रहा है कि सर
ये बोरिंग हो गया है या बार-बार क्या
चीजें हमें बताई जा रही है ये नया है सर
हमारे लिए हमें समझ में नहीं आ रहा ऐसा है
किसी के साथ तो प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए
उसके बाद एक कमेंट मैं आपको देता हूं।
रन साइलेंटली
साइलेंटली विदाउटिंग
टर्मिनल विंडज
ओके उसके लिए भी हमारे पास क्या है?
सेल
उसके बाद
सेल सीएमडी उसके बाद
वीबी हाइड
कुछ हो गया उसके बाद मैं आपको एक मैसेज
बॉक्स ऑफ टाइप कर देता हूं।
वैसे लोग कम आने लगे अभी
एंटप्राइज
सिक्योर
सेशन
इनिशलाइज्ड
टी
आई
अच्छा जी इनिशलाइज्ड
सिक्योर सेशन इनिशलाइज बस इतना ही मैं अभी
मैसेज करने वाला हूं और यह है हमारे पास
कंप्लीट तो मैं अभी आपको एक चीज समझा देता
हूं यह तो मैं अभी एग्जीक्यूट नहीं करने
वाला और ना इसको मैं सेव करने वाला तो मैं
आपको एक पीपीटी पर ले चलता हूं अभी ओके
तो अभी मैं क्या समझाने वाला हूं कि
बिहाइंड द सीन क्या है कि यह कैसे काम
करने वाला है? बिहाइंड द सीन ये कैसे काम
करने है? ये जो स्टेजर है ये कैसे काम
करने वाला है? इसके बारे में बात करने
वाले हैं। ठीक है? तो
मैंने एक कमांड बताई है आई एक्स न्यू
ऑब्जेक्ट नेट वेब क्लाइंट डाउन
मतलब
इस इस पूरे पेलोड के जो बैकबोन है यही
कमांड है। इस पूरे पेलोड की बैकबोन यही
कमांड है जो मैंने आपको हाईलाइट की है। यह
कमांड क्या कर रही है? यह कमांड एक स्टेजर
की तरह काम कर रही है। कैसे काम कर रही
है? यह क्या कर रही है? जो अटैकर्स का जो
रिमोट सर्वर है अटैकर का जो रिमोट सर्वर
है यहां पर क्या है आपका एक रिमोट सर्वर
है जो हमने होस्ट किया है पython की हेल्प
से यहां पर अटैकर का एक रिमोट सर्वर यहां
पे हमने क्या किया हुआ है होस्ट किया है
उससे क्या कर रही है कमांड ये कमांड आपकी
जो मलेशियस स्क्रिप्ट है उस मलेशियस
स्क्रिप्ट को डायरेक्टली आपकी जो rेम है
rेम के अंदर क्या कर रही है वह
rेम के अंदर क्या कर रही है? डाउनलोड कर
रही है और डाउनलोड करके उसको रन कर रही है
बिना हार्ड डिस्क पर सेव किए। ठीक है? दिस
कमांड एक्ट एज स्टेजर पैचिंग ए रिमोट
स्क्रिप्ट डायरेक्टली इनू रेम फ्रॉम ए
अटैकर कंट्रोलोल्ड कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
सर्वर विदाउट सेविंग इट टू द लोकल हार्ड
डिस्क। वही मैंने आपको बताया। यह कमांड इस
पोस्ट से फाइल को डाउनलोड कर रही है।
डाउनलोड करके डायरेक्टली मेमोरी के अंदर
डायरेक्टली रैेम के अंदर उसको एग्जीक्यूट
कर रही है। जैसे आप डबल क्लिक करके इनेबल
कंटेंट पर क्लिक कर देते हो। बस ऐसे ही तो
इस कमांड को समझते हैं। सबसे पहले कैसे
न्यू ऑब्जेक्ट सिस्टम डॉट वेब क्लाइंट इट
क्रिएट एन इंस्टेंस ऑफ द डॉट नेट सिस्टम.
डॉट वेब क्लाइंट क्लास विद इन द पावर सेल
एनवायरमेंट। बेसिकली मैं आपको समझा देता
हूं कि आपकी जो यह फर्स्ट लाइन है उसमें
जो लिखी हुई है इसका मतलब क्या है कि यह
एक इंस्टेंस क्रिएट कर रही है डॉट नेट एक
क्लास होती है वो क्लास कौन सी है सिस्टम
नेट डॉट वेब क्लाइंट की एक क्लास है उसका
एक ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट कर रही है अब यह
ऑब्जेक्ट क्या करता है यह ऑब्जेक्ट वेब से
डेटा डाउनलोड करने के लिए यूज़ किया जाता
है वेब से डेटा डाउनलोड करने के लिए इस
ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज किया जाता है उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट क्या है जब ऑब्जेक्ट तो हमने
क्रिएट कर लिया। अब ऑब्जेक्ट क्रिएट करने
के बाद उसके अंदर एक मेथड होता है जो
एक्चुअल में क्या करता है? वह डेट डाउनलोड
करेगा। तो द डाउनलोड स्ट्रिंग ए मेथड दैट
ट्रांसमिट एन एचटीपी गेट रिक्वेस्ट टू द
स्पेसिफाइड यूआरएल। क्या मतलब क्या है? कि
ये क्या है? यह एक मेथड है वेब क्लाइंट
क्लास का। यह मेथड क्या करता है? यह जो
यूआरएल हमने यहां पर प्रोवाइड किया है उस
यूआरएल यूआरएल के साथ एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
क्या करता है? एचटीटीपी गेट रिक्वेस्ट
भेजता है और उसके बाद क्या है कि जैसे ही
यह http गेट रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है तो अटैकर
का जो सर्वर है उस रिक्वेस्ट को रिसीव
करता है। रिसीव करने के बाद जो पेड डॉट पी
पीs1 है या जो power डॉट पीs1 की जो आपकी
स्क्रिप्ट फाइल है उसको उठाकर क्या कर
देता है? रिस्पांस में आपकी जो टारगेट
मशीन है उसके पास भेज देता है। अभी क्या
है कि नेटवर्क में उस फाइल पे ना तो कोई
इंक्रिप्शन यूज़ किया गया है। वो फाइल क्या
है? प्लेन टेक्स्ट में है। इसीलिए क्या
होता है कि जब वो फाइल प्लेन टेक्स्ट में
है तो उसको डायरेक्टली क्या कर लेता है?
यह
डायरेक्टली टेक्स्ट स्ट्रिंग के रूप में
रिसीव कर लेता है। डायरेक्टली टेक्स्ट
स्ट्रिंग के रूप में रिसीव कर लेता है।
ओके? उसके बाद नेक्स्ट आई एक्स इसके अंदर
आपकी ये दोनों चीज है। ये भी और ये भी ये
दोनों चीज कहां पर है? इसके अंदर है। ये
क्या है? इनवोक एक्सप्रेशन। ये आपकी क्या
है? इनवोक एक्सप्रेशन। बेसिकली ये कमांड
क्या करती है? यह पावरफुल की सबसे खतरनाक
कमांड लाइन है। कैसे? यह क्या करती है?
इसको जो भी आप टेक्स्ट या स्ट्रिंग पास
करते हो वो क्या करती है? यह समझती है कि
एक वैलिड पावर सेल कमांड या स्क्रिप्ट है
जिसको यह तुरंत एग्जीक्यूट करना स्टार्ट
कर देती है। जो आईई एक्स है इनवोक
एक्सप्रेशन को आप जो भी कमांड या जो भी
टेक्स्ट या जो भी स्ट्रिंग पास करते हो यह
उसको एक वैलिड पावर सेल स्क्रिप्ट या
वैलिड पावर सेल कमांड के रूप में क्या
करती है? देखती है। और यह समझ के
डायरेक्टली उसको क्या कर देती है?
एग्जीक्यूट कर देती है। इमीडिएटली उसको
इमीडिएटली क्या कर देती है? एग्जीक्यूट कर
देती है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? यहां तक सबको
क्लियर है?
यह कमांड अच्छे से क्लियर है सबको?
ये कमांड अच्छे से क्लियर है सबको?
क्लियर है
ओके
तो नेक्स्ट
उसके बाद क्या हो गया जब आपने डबल क्लिक
किया आपका पेलोड डाउनलोड हो गया आपका
पेलोड डाउनलोड हो गया रेम के अंदर रैेम के
अंदर डाउनलोड होने के बाद उसको एग्जीक्यूट
भी करना है तो एग्जीक्यूट करने के बाद
आपको क्या करना है एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए
उसकी कमांड होती है क्योंकि पावर आपने
किसके अंदर कर लिया rेम के अंदर डाउनलोड
अब उसको एग्जीक्यूट करना है एग्जीक्यूट
करके रिवर्स सेल चाहिए तो उसके लिए एक
कमांड है पावर कैट हफन सी आपका आईपी
एड्रेस हफन पी किस पोर्ट पर और कौन क्या
करना करवाना है तो यह वो कमांड है जो आपको
रिवर्स सेल प्रोवाइड करेगी यह कमांड क्या
है आपकी क्या करती है यह टारगेट मशीन पर
एक रिवर्स सेल इस्टैब्लिश करती है किसके
साथ उस पर्टिकुलर आईपी एड्रेस और पोर्ट
नंबर के साथ और आपको क्या करती है रिमोट
एक्सेस देती है इस टारगेट मशीन का वाया
सीएम एमडी मतलब जो सेल एक्सेस मिलता है वो
कौन सा एक सेल एक्सेस मिलता है? सीएमडी
मिलता है। टारगेट मशीन अंडरस्टुड सीएमडी
का एक्स मिलता है। द दिस फाइनल
एग्जीक्यूशन स्ट्रिंग कमांड्स ए टारगेट
मशीन टू ओपन ए सॉकेट कनेक्शन बैक टू द
अटैकर्स आईपी एड्रेस फॉर द पर्टिकुलर
पोर्ट एंड सक्सेसफुली बाइंडिंग एंड
पाइपिंग एंड इंटर इंटैक्टिव विंडोज कमांड
प्र्प ओवर द नेटवर्क स्ट्रीम।
एक मिनट दे रहा हूं। इसको एक बार देख
लीजिए। नहीं समझ में आए तो प्लीज मुझसे
पूछ लीजिए।
गाइस गिव मी
30 सेकंड
ओम
तो सबको समझ में आ गया?
सबको समझ में आ गया? तो चलो मैं
प्रैक्टिकली चलते हैं अभी। ठीक है? इसको
प्रैक्टिकली देखते हैं। तो प्रैक्टिकली
देखते हैं। तो हम अपनी टारगेट मशीन को रन
करते हैं।
ये हमारी टारगेट मशीन है। इन दोनों को हम
डिलीट कर देते हैं। इसके बाद अभी मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं? एक नई फाइल क्रिएट करेंगे।
Microsoft Word ओके।
इसको वो करते हैं। उससे पहले मैं एक काम
कर देता हूं। हमेशा इसमें रियल टाइम ऑन हो
जाता है।
ओके नेक्स्ट अभी हम चलते हैं इसके अंदर
मैं इस फाइल को सेव करूंगा तो सेव एज एंड
मैं अभी डेस्कटॉप के ऊपर ही करने वाला हूं
डेमो
डेमो ओके उसके बाद इसका फाइल का एक्सटेंशन
रहेगा 97 वाला सेव किया गो टू डेवलपर टैब
विजुअल बेसिक दिस डॉक्यूमेंट एंड इसको हम
क्या करते हैं? यहां से कॉपी करते हैं।
कंट्रोल ऑल कंट्रोल सी अभी हम लास्ट लास्ट
दिन वाली गलती नहीं करने वाले और यहां पर
क्या करने वाले हैं? पेस्ट कर दिया हमने।
तो यहां पर हमने कंप्लीट मे बी कोई गलती
नहीं की है। तो सबसे पहले हम क्या करते
हैं? काली लinक्स पे चलते हैं। और काली
लinक्स पे चलने के बाद
वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट
ये प्रॉब्लम है इसकी
ओके। अभी यहां पर हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
Python सर्वर स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं। ओके।
तो Python के लिए स्टार्ट करते हैं।
Python
Python 3 hनm
http डॉट ओके।
इसका किसी को सोलशन पता है क्या?
http डॉट सर्वर एंड 8 08 8 जीरो मे बी
इट्स ओके फाइन ओके यह सही है। उसके बाद
हमें नेट कैश लिसनर भी स्टार्ट करना है।
एंड
कीबोर्ड चेंज करके देख लिया।
टी हफ
एल वी एन टी
वन थ्री थ्री 7 ये हमारा पोर्ट था।
स्टार्ट कर दिया लिसनिंग और इसके बाद मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं? क्लोज करता हूं और हम
चलते हैं विंडो पर। तो इसको रन करके
देखें।
पहले रन करके देखें।
इसको सेव कर देते हैं। कंट्रोल एस सेव कर
दिया। और इसको मैं क्या करता हूं? क्लोज
कर देता हूं। इसको भी क्लोज कर देता हूं।
फाइल को करते हैं। ओपन
ओपन पुट एंटप्राइज सिक्योर सेशन
इनिशिएटेड। ओके गो टू अकाली लinक्स यह
रहा।
यहां से कनेक्शन एस्टैब्लिश हुआ और यहां
पर हमें यह मिल गया यूजर वन ड्राइव
डेस्कटॉप अगर हम क्या करें? आईपी नहीं
करेंगे। इसमें हम क्या करने हु एम आई?
हु
एम
हु एम आई ये देखो टेस्ट केस एचड कुमार अगर
हम सिस्टम इनेशन देखें वो देखते हैं
इनफो
यह देखो
तो मिल गया हमें
मिल गया हमें अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
समझ में आया आज का पेलोड
किसी को कोई डाउट है आज की क्लास में आज
का इतना ही था
आज का इतना ही था
छोटी सी क्लास थी आई होप सबको समझ में आ
गई होगी
सबको समझ में आया बेसिक क्लियर हो रहे हैं
सबके?
किसी को कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास।
क्योंकि नेक्स्ट क्लास अभी क्या है कि मैं
कुछ ज्यादा क्लासेस नहीं है बट जितनी
क्लासेस है काफी इंपॉर्टेंट क्लासेस बची
हुई हैं तो वो मैं आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास
संडे को होगी क्योंकि कल मैं क्लास लेने
वाला था आपकी बट कल क्लास नितेश सर कुछ
अनाउंसमेंट करने वाले हैं तो इसीलिए मैं
कल क्लास नहीं ले सकता तो संडे को आपकी
क्लास होगी
संडे को आपकी क्लास होगी। यहीं से
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। इसका थोड़ा सा ऑफ स्केशन
मतलब बेस 64 वर्जन यूज करेंगे। ओके?
इसका बेस 64 वर्जन है। वो डिजाइन करके
एग्जीक्यूट करना सिखाऊंगा। उसके बाद फिर
फदर देखते हैं कि और क्या-क्या मुझे
करवाना है इसी में। क्योंकि अभी देखो
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक 60 क्लास नंबर 60 से चल
रहा है आपका।
क्लास नंबर 60 से चल रहा है और अभी यह
जल्दी ही एंड होने वाला है अगली पांच से
10 क्लासेस में।
यह एंड होने के बाद
नेक्स्ट हम या तो फिर आपका पावर सेल
करवाएंगे। बेसिक ऑफ पावर सेल पावर सेल
स्क्रिप्टिंग मतलब पावर सेल कैसे काम करती
है उसकी कमांड लाइन पर आपकी हैंड्स ऑन
करवाऊंगा। उसके बाद
क्योंकि मैं चाहता था कि पहले आपको
एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग में बहुत सारी
चीजें सिखाऊं लेकिन मुझे लगता है अभी आपको
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन भी सीखना है तो उस पे
मैं फोकस करने की सोच रहा हूं नेक्स्ट बट
उसके लिए फिर अगर आप लोग नहीं आओगे बस
उसकी अभी तक मैं अपनी अवेलेबिलिटी के बारे
में नहीं कह सकता बट आई विल ट्राई कि मैं
अवेलेबल हूं और मैं फिर उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
वो करूंगा उसका प्रॉमिस अभी नहीं है बट
मेरा नेक्स्ट फोकस बस वही है।
रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग तो इसका पार्ट नहीं
है। रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग तो सिलेबस ही अलग
है ब्रो।
दैट इज टोटली डिफरेंट। सिलेबस टोटली
डिफरेंट कांसेप्ट।
सारी चीजें एक बार में नहीं पढ़ा सकता
मैं।
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। मिलते हैं
संडे को। तो संडे को भी सेम टाइम ही मिलते
हैं हम। ओके? तो बाय-ब एवरीवन। गुड नाइट
एवरीवन। सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।